[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي الاختيار استهلو هذا ابرز
العناوين
[تصفيق]
باكثر من 100 صاروخ روسيا تقصف بعنف كياف
وخر كاف والفيفا وتسببت بانقاعات واسعه
للكهرباء والانترنت
وفي مجموعه العشرين اجتماع على تفادي
المواجهه بين القوى الكبرى وتحريم استخدام
السلاح النووي
لارتباطه بايران دعوات لاغلاق مركز
هامبورغ الاسلاميه والاستخبارات الالمانيه
تعتبره اداه بروباندا لطهران باوروبا
[موسيقى]
ربي
الانتخابات عام 2014
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نبدا المشاهدين من التصعيد اللافت في
اوكرانيا حيث قصفت روسيا مئه صاروخ خلال
يوم واحد في انحاء المتفرقه من البلاد
مستهدفه محطات الطاقه واهداف حكوميه على
كل من كياف وحركاب والفيف فيما دوه
انفجارات في مناطق اخرى في البلاد ما دفع
الى اطلاق سفارات الانذار في كافه العلياء
ودعوات للبقاء في الملاج وتسبب القص
الصاروخي العنيف من قطاع الطاقه عن عده
مناطق جراء القصف فيما اعلنت شبكه نت
بلوكس عن اضطراب كبير في خدمه الانترنت في
اوكرانيا بعد هذه الهجره
[موسيقى]
تاثير القصر الروسيه لجيران اوكرانيا اذا
ابلغت مولدوفا عن انقطاعات هائله للكهرباء
في انحاء البلاد بعد غرات عسكريه روسيه
على البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في اوكرانيا
والتي اسقطت خطا مهما للكهرباء يمد الدوله
بطاقتها وقال هنا وزير البنيه التحتيه في
مولدوفا بعد قصف روسيا لنظام الطاقه
الاكرانيه انقطع احد خطوط الطاقه الذي
يؤمن انطلاق الكهرباء الى بلادنا وادى ذلك
الى انقطاعات هائله للكهرباء في انحاء
البلاد اشار الى ان خطوط الطاقه التي
اسقطت لم تتضرر وان من قطع تلقائيا
كاجراءا للامان واضاف ان الشركه المزوده
تعمل على استعاده الكهرباء واوضح انه سيتم
ابلاغ المواطنين في مولدوفا في تحديثات
الامر
اذا تطورات عسكريه ميدانيه متسارعه تشهدها
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في جنوب
اوكرانيا حيث قالت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه تواصل تجهيز
خطوط دفاعيه جديده على الضفه اليسرى لنهر
النيبرو غرب خرسون وهذا بعد ما قامت
بالانسحاب بشكل مفاجئ من مدينه خيرسون
وتمركزت على الجهه المقابله للنهر ما سمح
للقوات الاوكرانيه من السعاده السيطره على
المدينه في اشاره الى ان الهدف المقبل
للقوات الاوكرانيه هو السعاده يتم التحضير
لخطه عسكريه تكتيكيه لاستعاده المنطقه
الواقعه شمال شرقي خيرسون حيث يواصل الجيش
الاوكراني حشد قواته للمعركه الكبيره
وتواصل تعزيز تحركاته حتى يتمكن من شق
طريقه رئيسي نحو ملكوبال ذات الاهميه
الاقليميه هذا هو اكدت الدفاع الاوكرانيه
بان الجيش الروسي يقوم بعمليات هجوميه في
مناطق
بالجرافكا وارتيموس
وبخموتوسكي وعدد اخرى من المناطق
كشف رئيس الشيشان رمضان قدير وفاه عن عدد
المقاتلين الشيشان المشاركين في الحرب في
اوكرانيا والذين تجاوز عددهم 20,000 مقاتل
شيشانيه منذ بدء الحربي في اوكرانيا و
تسعه الاف منهم موجودين حاليا على خط
المواجهه مشددا على ان المقاتلين من
جمهوريه الشيشان نجحوا بالمهام الموكله
اليهم منذ الايام الاولى للحرب في
اوكرانيا واكد قديروف على نقل الصندوق
العام الاقليمي اكثر من 20,000 طن من
المساعدات الانسانيه لسكان الاراضي
المحرره على حد وصفه
قبل ذلك اجتمع وزراء خارجيه والدفاع
للاتحاد الاوروبي اليوم لمناقشه تطورات
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا الاجتماع تم
بحضور امين عام حلف الناتو وتمت مناقشه
عدد من القضايا ابرزها مكافحه القرصنه
والقدرات المشتركه والتدريبات العسكريه
حيث صرح جوزيف بريل ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي
للشؤون الخارجيه ان الاتحاد سيطلق مهمه
تدريب 15 الف جندي اوكرانيه وان قوه
التدخل السريع ستكون جاهزه في عام 2025
في فلسطين 15 الف جنديا اوكرانيا سيتم
تدريبهم في مختلف الدول الاوروبيه الاعضاء
سيكون جهدا مهما للتجديد وزياده قدره
الجيش الاوكراني ستكون هذه المهمه جوهر
دعمنا العسكري لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
حيث استعرض عدد من قاده المجموعه
طرفي الازمه الى وقتها حتى لا تتوسع
عالميات في هذا الاطار اكد وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سرجراف بانهم منعت السيسي البيان
الختامي لقمه ال 20 مشاهده على ان بلاده
جاهزه للتفاوض لكن اوكرانيا هي التي ترفض
التوصل لاتفاق وقال لافروف ان اتهام روسيا
بالعدوان على اوكرانيا استفزاز مقصود لكن
في ذات الوقت اشار الى ان هناك الكثير من
الدول لم تنضم للعقبات ضد روسيا
بالموازات اعتبرت مسوده بيان قمه العشرين
التي تعقد في جزيره بالي باندونيسيا ان
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه والتهديد بها غير
مقبوله وجاء في المسوده ان معظم الاعضاء
يدينون بشده الحرف اوكرانيا دعينا الى
ضروره تمديد صفقه الحبوب الاوكرانيه
واضافت المسوده ان المجموعه تبدي انشغالها
بتاثير الحرب في اوكرانيا على الاقتصاد
العالمي وشهدت طبعا القمه تصريحات ناريه
بدلها كل من الرئيس الاوكراني مع وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
استعاده مثل عمليه انزال نورماندي
ولا مصلحه نفسه
[موسيقى]
بانشاء محكمه خاصه لمحاكمه شخصيه على
خلفيه حرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
الاتحاد الاوروبي
في حرب هجينه باوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لن نقبل باي صيغه سلام لا تضمن سحب روسيا
قواتها وتشكيلاتها المسلحه من بلادنا
[موسيقى]
جميع المشاكل في تسويه حول اوكرانيا هي من
جانبك يافا
سي المفردات العربيه ناديه يعني امام
الانقسام بموضوع الاصطفاف بالحرب الروسيه
هناك يعني تاكيد على اهميه التصدي لهشاشه
الاقتصاد العالمي اليوم ما ابرز ما جاء في
هذا اليوم من تصريحات ومن مواقف السياسيه
اهلا بك ليال قبل ان اجيب على هذا السؤال
في الواقع واريد ان اوضح نقطه قبل قليل
تحدث مع مسؤول رفيع المستوى في الاداره
الامريكيه عن مسوده النهائيه طبعا
المستودع النهائيه التي ستصدر غدا في
نهايه اعمال قمه العشرين قال بان الولايات
المتحده لم تكن 9 ربما الى ايدانا مباشره
بمعنى بان الدول مجموعه ال20 لم تكن تريد
ان تقول باننا ندين الغزو او الاعتداء
الروسي على اوكرانيه لكنها بطريقه ما او
كانت هناك همم صياغه تقول بان كل هذه
الدول تريد بالفعل ان تقول بان سيكون هناك
تاثير على الاقتصاد العالمي بشكل هش بسبب
الحرب على اكره على على اوكرانيا وايضا
التاثير المرتبط بالامن الغذائي وامن
الطاقه لكن الان بعد هذا الهجوم الصاروخ
وبينما كنا نتحدث مع هذا المسؤول صدر بيان
في البيت الابيض طبعا باسم جاكيت سلفا كان
يتحدث عن قلق عميق لدول مجموعه على 20
هذا الاعتداء الذي وصفه بانه اعتداء على
المدنيين وقال بانه سنعكس سلبا على مجموعه
العشرين طبعا اليوم كان يوم مهم للقضايا
التي طرحت همم خصوصا في نصف النهائي من
همم القمه عندما كانت شراكه بين الرئيس
بيدن والاتحاد الاوروبي والمجموعه كلها
طبعا برئاسه اندونيسيا وكان هناك حديث عن
تخصيص 600 مليار دولار لمشاريع تنمويه
سواء كانت البيئه التحتيه سواء كانت
الاستثمار الرقم او للتغيير المناخي بما
فيها اندونيسيا التي تريد الولايات
المتحده ان تتحول من استخدام الفحم الصخري
الى طبعا لتوليد الكهرباء الى الطاقه همم
وهو همم بطريقه ما هو تعبيد الطريق رسم
خريطه
طبعا للمؤتمر القادم لهذه المجموعه في
الهند 20 23 طبعا الفتره قصيره لتحقيق كل
هذه الاهداف لكن نستطيع ان نقول بان هناك
ب بايجابيه همم طبعا التركيز على شق
السياسي سواء كانت الحرب في اوكرانيا او
حتى اللقاء الذي جمع رئيس بدر مع الشيش
بينج همم كان اكيد سيؤثر سياسيا لكن
الاقتصاد هو الحاضر بالدرجه الاولى البيئه
الجهوزيه للعالم كله همم بمواجهه وباء مثل
وباء كرونه وكما تعرفين تصادف حتى هذا
المؤتمر مع الاعلان عن الاحصاء الجديد
لسكان الكره الارضيه والذين وصلوا الى
ثمانيه مليار هذا الاعلان همم ما الذي
يمكن القول عنه خصوصا انه ايضا يمثل تحدي
جديد مع التغيير المناخي مع الالتزمات
الدوليه التي اصبحت هائله على الدول
المتقدمه بظل يعني الالتزامات التي يجب ان
تقدمها للدول الفقيره او الناميه
الى حد كبير اولا كنا نتحدث عن مجموعه
السبع الصناعيه وهي الديمقراطيات الغربيه
الى جانب طبعا الصين عفوا اليابان وكندا
واستراليا واليابان لكن ااه واليابان الى
ذلك الى ذلك هناك باقي دول مجموعه العشرين
طبعا التي هي تتمتع باقتصاد قوي ويمكن ان
تلعب دور ايجابي في الفعل في تغيير اقتصاد
العالم لكن الازمات التي مرت في العالم
والان نتحدث عن زياده في عدد سكان الكره
الارضيه ستصاعد من هذه التحديات وايجاد
حلول عمليه لها يعني عندما نتحدث عن عالم
مترابط هذه الازمه التي رايناها سواء كانت
الحرف في اوكرانيا لم جغرافيا لم تكن
محدوده في هذه المنطقه يعني اثرت على كل
العالم سواء كانت في اوروبا بالنسبه للغاز
الروسي وازمه الطقس وكانت في الولايات
المتحده وارتفاع اسعار المواد المحروقات
والمواد الاساسيه الغذائيه اذا العالم
مرتبط بشكل كبير وعلى كل القاده العالم هو
ربما هذه النقطه مهمه جدا لانه كان هناك
لقاءات ثنائيه على هامش هذه القمه وغدا
سيكون اللقاء الاخير للرئيس بايدل مع رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ايضا همم وسيكون هناك
الحديث بعمق عن كل هذه القضايا كيف يمكن
للدول الصناعيه والدول التي تتمتع باقتصاد
قوي ان تساعد الدول الفقيره جزء منها كان
ايضا هيكلت اعاده الديون في دول مثل تشاد
وايضا انجاد حلول بيئيه لدول صغيره سواء
كانت في المحيط الهندي او في المحيط
الهادي شكرا
[موسيقى]
حضر رئيس اللجنه الاولمبيه الدوليه توماس
باخ من رغبه بعض الحكومات الى حظر مشاركه
الرياضيين الروس من اولمبياد باريس للعام
2024 على خلفيات الحرب على اوكرانيا داعيا
الى الفصل بين السياسه والرياضه في
المنافاسات الاولمبيه وقلب خلال تصريحات
له في قمه العشرين ان الدول باتت تحدد
المنافسين في البطولات على اساس السياسي
وليس بسبب تفوقهم رياضيا محذرا من ان ذلك
قد يقود الى انهيار الرياضه
الحكومات في تحديد الرياضيين الذين سيسمح
لهم بالمشاركه في المسابقات الرياضيه
الدوليه واي رياضيين لن يسمح لهم بذلك لقد
فعلوا ذلك لاسباب سياسيه بحته انهم يريدون
ان يقرروا اي رياضي يمكنه الان التاهل
والمنافسه في النهايه في الالعاب
الاولمبيه باريس 2014 اذا اصبحت الرياضه
بهذه الطريقه مجرد اداء اخرى لتحقيق اهداف
سياسيه فان الرياضه الدوليه ستنهار
[موسيقى]
كشفت العديد من التحليلات الاقتصاديه
الغربيه ان شركات النفط الامريكيه حققت
ارباحا خياليه بسبب تواصل العمليات
العسكريه الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
حيث بلغت ارباح شركات الطاقه الامريكيه
خلال الربع الثاني من عام 2022 نحو 70
مليار دولار جاء هذا في وقت تشهد فيه
الولايات المتحده معدله تضخم لارقام لم
تشهدها على مدار العقود الاربعه الماضيه
بسبب ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه وفي الوقت الذي
تسجل فيه العديد من شركات النفط الامريكيه
اربع خياليه تشكو اوروبا من كون امريكا
تبيع لها الغاز باربع اضعاف شعره لديها
حيث اكد الرئيس الفرنسي مع ريال مدريد
وانا بلاده لا يمكن ان تدفع لي امريكا ثمن
الغاز مضاعفا اربع مرات
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستعمله فيها بعد قليل
في ذكرى احتجاجات عام 2019 اضرابات واسعه
في ايران
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
يهدف لتوطيد العلاقات مع الصين في مجالات
الاستراتيجيه مهمه التقارب الغربي
صاحباتهم وحاولات لتحديد الصين عن روسيا
وتصحيح مسار العلاقات مع واشنطن وبعد نقطه
انطلاق جديده فخصوم الامس يسعون اليوم
لفتح صفحه جديده والهدف تجنب النزاعات
المستقبليه وفتح باب التعاون الاستراتيجي
المشترك ضمن خطه تذيب جليد خلافات عميقه
طال عمرها اليوم حدت الخلافات بين واشنطن
وبكين تراجعت بعد ما اكد رئيس بانه سيسعى
قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه مع الصين والتي يمكن
ان تلعب دورا فعالا في حل الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه الدوره ايضا على فرنسا حيث دعى
الرئيس الفرنسي مع ريال ماكرون نظيره
الصيني الى ضروره جلب روسيا الى طاوله
المفاوضات لايجاد حل للحرب في اوكرانيا
وتجنب التصعيد فتو الجهود الدوليه
للاستجابه للازمات العالميه بين بكين
والغرب بات الضروريه خصوصا وان العالم يمر
في مرحله من الاضطرابات والتحولات التي
تحتاج الى الانفتاح والتعاون وفق صحيفه لو
مود الفرنسي
يمنحني اجتماع اليوم الفرصه للتعبير عن
اراده لاعطاء دفعه جديده لتجديد تعاوننا
والانضمام الى بعضنا من اجل مواجهه
التحديات الدوليه الجميله
نقاط اختلاف كثيره تتمحور اساسا حول انشطه
الصين يسعى الغرب لتجاوزها بالتسويه
الوديه لانه بيت يعلم جيدا بان الصين
تعتبر لاعب اساسي في الاقتصاد العالمي
وباعتبارها طبعا ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في
العالم وبالتالي فان فتح مجال التعاون
معها وتوسيع الاستثمارات سيعود على اوروبا
بالفائده ووفق تقرير صادر عن مجله
الايكونوميوس فان الصين استثمرت ما يصل
الى 20 مليار دولار في الموانئ الاجنبيه
بين عام 2010 و 2020 وهنا نعود لزياره
المستشار الالمانيه الاخيره الى الصين
والتي اعادت للواجهها دوافع القرار
الالماني بخصوص السماح لشركه لشركه صينيه
بشراء حصه تبلغ نحو 25% من مرفارج الذي
يعاد اكبر موانئ البلاد وهو ما زاد طبعا
المحاوف الامريكيه من تمدد بكين بشبكه
موسعه في موانئ اجنبيه خصوصا وان معظم
الصفقات الصينيه تستهدف السيطره على
قطاعات من البنيه التحتيه الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من باريس الدكتور حسان القبه
الباحث في الاقتصاد السياسي دكتور حسان
يعني بالمرحله الماضيه ايام المستشاره
الالمانيه ميركل كان هناك توجه اوروبي
لضم روسيا وفصله عن الصيد بعد الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه بدات يعني التحليلات
تقول بالاتجاه المعاكس وهو ضم الصين لفصل
عن روسيا ولضغط على روسيا هل سينجح هذا
بظل عمق العلاقات الجنسيه والاقتصاديه بين
كل من الصين وروسيا
نعم بعد التحيه يا سيدتي الكريمه من خلال
كلا كل فريق العربيه وعموما المشاهدين في
ظل اطار عالمي متقلب ومناخ اقتصادي هش
للغايه التحالفات يبدو انها تتغير من فتره
الى فتره اخرى ولكن الاكيد والمتاكد ان
اليوم التحالف الصيني الروسي هو التحالف
استراتيجي للمدائق الطويل بالرغم ان كل
بلد يحسب حساباتها الخاصه خاصه هنا اتحدث
عن الصين بخصوص حساباتها الاقتصاديه مع
باقي العالم وطموح الصين ان همم
الاولى على الاقتصاد العالمي وهو ما تشتغل
عليه ربما ليس الغد ولكن على المدى
المتوسط والبعيد همم بالنسبه لاوروبا
اوروبا امامها تحديات كبيره وكبيره جدا
كما تفضلت سيد الكريمه ان يبدو ان تصريحات
المسؤولين الاوروبيين او الرؤساء
الاوروبيين في ضفه وتصريحات شرم الشيخ
التي يستمعت الي ومع انتداب قمه العشرين
تكون في ضفه اخرى حيث نبا شرم ميشال من
خطوره ربما تمادي العلاقات او تفطن
الاوروبيون وتفضل كل العالم ابان ازمه
كورونا اننا حولنا الصين الى مصنع العالم
الكبير مصنع العالم الكبير الذي يعاون
عليه الجميع حتى في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وليس في اوروبا فقط نتذكر جيدا
في خظم حرب ترامب على الصين والفيروس
الصيني وكل هذا الكلام نتذكر كيف حذرت
الصين الاوروبيين من اتخاذ اي قرار ضد
الصين وكان هناك مشروع في الاتحاد
الاوروبي السحب بعد التحليل الصيني
العلاقات الاوروبيه الصينيه علاقات
على المستوى الاقتصادي علاقات قويه جدا
مفيده جدا يبدو ان اوروبا اول كذلك على
الصين للخروج من ازمتها
الاقتصاديه كل التقارير انا طلعت على
البنك الدولي صندوق النقد الدولي اخرها
منظمه همم التعاون على اقتصادي لو ايوه
تقول ان الاقتصاد العالمي اسال القادم سوف
يدخل في ازمه مؤشرات النمو سوف تكون سلبيه
في المانيا يصفر فصل 7% للسنه القادمه
بريطانيا ربما سوف يكون نسبه التنميه صفر
فرنسا نتحدث عن فصل 6% ال- اا حتى
السياسات النقديه المتشدده للبنوك
المركزيه سواء في دلال الامريكي او البنك
المركزي الاوروبي سوف يحلق بطاله السنه
القادمه بدينا بدانا نشاهدها في شركه متى
فيسبوك
يعني هذه الازمه الاقتصاديه العالميه ايضا
من الفلسفات التي كانت موجوده ايام ماركل
هو عدم الاختيار بين الولايات المتحده
والصين خشيه الدخول بتكتلات تنتج ما كان
موجود ايام الحرب البارده هل ادركت اوروبا
خطوره الذهاب الى تكتل مع طرف واحد خصوصا
تمسك باغلبيه الاقتصاد العالمي
نعم حقيقه
بصفه النسبيه وممكن ضعيفه ممكن المؤشر
الايجابي هو تحول تشوز الى الصين في
انتظار ربما فتح القنوات من جديد وماكرون
كنت استمع منذ قليل الذي يدعوا الصين
لممارسه الضغوطات ادبيه على روسيا للجلوس
على طاوله مفاوضات لان بعد ما جرى في
بريطانيا وازمه خاصه هنا سوف اتحدث عن
السنهديه الحكوميه البريطانيه التي 29%
منها مملوكه للخارج ومن هنا قد تكون هذه
القناه التي قد تنقل الازمه الاقتصاديه من
بريطانيا الى الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي وحتى
تقرير صندوق النقد الدولي تحدث ان ممكن
همم اكثر دوله مهدئه هيطاليه بحكم كذلك
هشاشه
القوي الايطاليا هنا تخوف من العدوى كنا
نتحدث عن عدوى عدوى كرونا اليوم نتحدث
ازمه اقتصاديه وازمه ماليه ان تصبح هذه
الازمه في كل اوروبا
اهميه الاقتصاد الالماني لكل اوروبا اليوم
عذرا المقاطعه ولكن الوقت ضيق اليوم همم
هناك مناداه بان الصين شريك منافس ولكن
خصم استراتيجي وبالتالي لا يجب المبالغه
بالاعتماد عليه اقتصاديا كيف يمكن
الموازنه او اللعب على وتر هذا يعني
الانقسام
يعني كما كما قلت يعني تصريحات شرم ميشيل
في ضفه وتصريحات الرؤساء الاوروبيين
ماكروا او حتى تشويس في ضفه اخرى يبدو ان
الصين اليوم احكمت نتحدثون خاصه كما تفضلت
على المسجد 20 مليار استثمار في المانيا
وحتى المانيا دخلت في شركه 25% مع اكبر
الميناء اليوم في اطار العولمه التي
يعيشها العالم لا يمكن فصل البلد عن بلد
اخر حتى روسيا روسيا اليوم التي يعمل على
همم فرض عقوبات خاصه هنا تحدث في اوروبا
لا يمكن اليوم التعويل في المدى المتوسط
وحتى البعيد باربع اضعاف للغاز همم امريكي
في وقت من الاوقات سوف تكون هناك عقلينيه
اقتصاديه لان اليوم اوروبا ان كانت تريد
المحافظه على التنافسيتها في كل هذا
المشاكل الاقتصاد المفتوح مقارنه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مقارنه بالصين يجب
عليها البحث عن موارد الطاقه رخيصه الثمن
لان كلفه الانتاج في اوروبا سوف صح وسوف
تفقد اوروبا في مرحله من المراحل
التنافسيه في السوق العالميه وهذا لا يخدم
مصالح اوروبا وحتى انجيلا ميركر منذ فتره
كانت صرحت قالت لست اندم عن التحالف وخاصه
في مشروع نور ستريم مع روسيا وازدهار
اوروبا الاقتصادي كان بفضل
الحالي شكرا لك دكتور حسان القطبي
الباحث
تبحث السلطات الالمانيه في امكانيه اغلاق
مركز هامبرج الاسلاميه المرتبط بايران بعد
التصويت انه في البرلمان على طلب يدعوا
الحكومه لبحث اغلاقه وفي هامبر يشكل
المركز مصدر قلق للمعارضين الايرانيين
والمخابرات الالمانيه
يعرف هذا المسجد بالمسجد الازرق ومن بعيد
يبدو بمركز همبرجر اسلامي مجرده مسجدا
للصلاه ولكن المركز يثير مخاوف المعارضين
الايرانيين هنا الذين بداوا يتظاهرون
امامه ويثير ايضا قلق المخابرات الالمانيه
التي تراقبه منذ العام
1993 هذه السيده الايرانيه الالمانيه تروج
منذ سنوات لاغلاقه تقول تركيا
اليوم
بالنسبه لهم الشريعه تعلو فوق الدستور هنا
ما يعني بان العاملين في المركز لا
يحترمون القانون الاساسي في المانيا ولا
الدستور ويريدون النشره ايديولوجيههم عبر
كامل اوروبا وهي افكار ارهابيه
ويعرف السيسي هنا في همبرجر جيدا الدوره
التي يلعبه المركز في تركيا
يتحدث عن دور نموذج للمركز الذي يعين
رئيسه مباشره من طهران ويقول انه يلعب دور
سياسيا ودينيا ولكن فيزوكي يرفض اتهامات
احزاب المعارضه بالتردد في اغلاقه
ولا يكفي ان تقرر بعض الاحزاب السياسيه
الاغلاق لانه هناك اجراءات قانونيه ليس من
الضروري ان ياتي هذا الطلب من السياسيين
لان المركز اصلا تحت المراقبه وسيبقى كذلك
وان كانت هناك مناسبه لاغلاقه فسيتم
اغلاقه
تقدم بطلب من قبل ايام مجلس الشورى الذي
ينضوي المركز تحته من اتفاق مع حكومه
همبرج لترضي المركز الاسلامي منه خطوه قد
تكون الاولى باتجاه اغلاقه
المخابرات الالمانيه تصف هذا المركز بانه
اهم اداه بروباندا لايران في اوروبا
بجامعات ارهابيه مثل حزب الله والحوثيين
والان بعد عقودا من السماح له بالعمل
بحريه قد تكون ايام المركز الاسلامي فيها
برج باتت معدوده
اكدت وزيره خارجيه المانيا ان مجلس محافظي
الوكاله الذريه سيصوت غدا على قرار يدعو
ايران للتعاون وصفه ما تقوم به السلطات
الايرانيه ضد الشعبها بالوحشيه وكما قالت
الوزيره ايضا ان على ايران السماح
للمفتشين الدوليين بالعوده الى موقعها
النوويه مشيره الى ان ايران تنتهي كل نقاط
اتفاق النووي تقريبا وان لا محادثات جاريه
مع ايران حاليا
الى الاحتجاجات في ايران حيث دعى مكتب
مفوض الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان الى
الافراج الفوري عن جميع المعتقلين في
ايران بسبب الاحتجاجات الاخيره واسقاط
التهم عنهم التي فجرها مقتل مهسا امين قبل
شهرين وقال جيرمي لورانس المتحدث باسم
المفوض الاممي لحقوق الانسان في بيان ان
قانون حقوق الانسان يحمل حق في التجمع
السلمي وحريه التعبير كما دعا الى التجميد
الفوري لعقوبه الاعدام والغاء احكام
الاعدام الصادره بحق المحتشر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اعتراف صريح
من داخل اروقه النظام الايراني يقر بان
الاحتجاجات شلت النظام بعكس ما كان متوقعا
وفق تسجيلات لمسؤول ايراني تم تسريبها
فبعد ان كانت اصابع الاتهام تتوجه دائما
الى الخارج والترويش لمؤامرات خارجيه
اعترف المسؤول بوجود ما سماها مساوئ
داخليه فضلا عن مشاكل اقتصاديه كلها
تراكمات وتسببت بتغذيه الاحتجاجات عقب
وفاه سامي المسؤول الايراني كشف نوايا
النظام وخطته القادمه تجاه المحتاجين
متحدثا عن ان السلطات ستلجا الى استخدام
مزيد من القوه الاحتواء المتظاهرين
واحتواء الاحتجاجات التي دخلت اسبوعها
التاسع
[موسيقى]
اه تمام
ورقم هذه الخطه القمعيه الجديده الا ان
المسؤول الايراني استبعد انهاء الاحتجاجات
بكبسه زر وفقه ووصفه داعيا السلطات الى حل
المشاكل صوره الانتعاش لدى النظام المسؤول
وصف النظام بانه عانى من شلل تحليلي بدايه
الاحتجاجات مشيرا في التسجيل الصوتي
المسرب ان رقعه الاحتجاجات اتسعت تزامنا
مع فتح الجامعات هذا ليس كل شيء في
التسريع الذي يعترف المسؤول الاستخبارات
الايراني بان الكثير من قتل الاحتجاجات
ابرياء كما كشف عن اعداد تقديريه
للمعتقلين من الاحتجاجات قائلا انها بلغت
15,000 شخص 70% منهم تتراوح اعمارهم بين
17 عاما و20 عاما و خلال تسجيله المسرب
هذا حذر المسؤول الايراني من ان بلاده
ستشهد اغتيالات وانفجارات مجهوله دون ان
يقدم تفصيل عن طبيعه او زمن هذه
الانفجارات
نور الاحتجاجاتي لا تخمد خناق يلف مدن
ايران
ينتفضوا اهلها على باب رزقهم حتى اغلاقات
لا تردد فيها لاحياء ذكرى قتل النظام
الايراني للمتظاهرين عام 2019
اصحاب المحل التجاريه والباعه في اسواق
ايران يقولون كلمتهم اضرابات عن العمل في
عده مدن ايرانيه دعما ايضا لمظاهرات خرجت
منذ شهرين لاسقاط النظام هكذا هو الحال
ملامح العصيان على اوجه المحلات في مختلف
المدن الايرانيه انضموا جميعهم الى دعوات
لمسيرات الاحتجاج العام لا شيء يوقفهم رغم
تهديدات النظام الايراني بتوسيع رقعه
الاعتقالات والاعدامات بين صفوف المحتاجين
كارثه وجوديه تواجه الشباب والقصر في
ايران بسبب الاعتقالات الاخيره بحسب وصف
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز اكدت في تقريرها
الاخير عن اعتقال ايران للمئات من
المشاركين في المظاهرات وقتل الكثيرين في
حمله قمع وحشيه تشنها السلطات واشارت
الصحيفه الى ان استهداف الشباب ياتي وسط
حمله للمحتجين تخللها اعتقاله
14,000 شخص اضافه الى استهداف للاطفال
وقتلي خمسين قاصرا على الاقل حتى الان
تهديد وواعيد من السلطات الايرانيه بحده
غير مسبوقه على مدى العقدين الماضيين بحسب
التقرير ايضا ما ينذروا بمستقبل انساني
يشطد ضبابيه اكثر فاكثر غذاء السالم
العربيه
حقوق الانسان الاحوازيه استاذ عمار سابدا
من موضوع التظاهرات اليوم النساء الجيل
الجديد الوعي المجتمعي التكنولوجيا الفقر
الذي حل بالطبقه الوسطى الايرانيه كلها
عوامل ادت الى عدم انطفاء هذه التظاهرات
والى اشتعالها اكثر اليوم بهذه الذكرى نحن
امام يعني مظاهره كبيره بكل المدن
الايرانيه هل سيستطيع ان النظام قبعه
تحيه لك وللمشاهدين الكرام طبعا بالاضافه
الى ما ذكرت هذه تراكمات وايضا هناك
النظام في الماضي لم يحاول ان يعدل من
سلوك في قضيه الاصلاحات وفي قضيه المطالبه
بالاصوات في 2009 وفي الاعوام التي تلت
عده مرات انتفضت الشعوب في ايران ولكن
النظام لم يسمع لم يكن عنده اذان ساقيه
واخر هذه الاحتجاجات التي شاهدناها هي تلك
التي اندلعت في نوفمبر 2019
الان في هذه الايام في الحقيقه تلك تلك
كانت ايضا انتفاضه واحتجاجات ومظاهرات
شاهدتها العديد من المدن الايرانيه بما
فيها مدينه محشور التي يقال انه سقط في
مجزره هور محشور العشرات العشرات من
الضحايا حيث همم القوات القمع استخدمت
القوات الثقيله
والرشاشات
لكم المتظاهرين وفي الحقيقه الذكرى
السنويه ساحتقد ان
الشعوب الايرانيه سوف تحيي هذه الفكره
خاصه وانهم وصلوا اعتقد حسب راي حسب قراءه
المشهد ان الشعوب الايرانيه وصلت الى
قناعه انه لابد وان تتخلص من هذا النظام
وفقدت الامل
بوافقد الامل كافه اطياف
وشرائع الشعوب الموجوده فيها الامل في
اصلاح هذا النظام وتريد اسقاطه الضغط
الاساسي ما سمعناه من التسريب عن المسؤول
الاستخبارات خصوصا ان هناك كم افواه
للمعارضين داخل السلطه وداخل النظام
الديني هل ممكن ان تكبر اذا ما اكملت
التظاهرات
بطبيعه الحال هو الضغط على المؤسسه ال ال
الدينيه او التسريب الذي شاهدنا في
الحقيقه هي هناك مجموعه او لنقل عصابه هي
التي تحكم وهي التي تمارس وتنقط وهناك
اتباع لها هنا وهناك في المؤسسه الدينيه
وفي الاجهزه القمعيه وبطبيعه الحال هذه
ليست محسنه على الضغوط الموجوده وخاصه ان
انما تشهده الساحه من غليان ما تشهده من
ثوره اعتقد سوف يقلب جميع الموازين وخاصه
ان هناك
منهم في ضمن النظام لا يريدون لا يريدون
ربما ان تتلقى ايديهم بدماء الشعوب من عام
2019 الى اليوم من شعار الاقتصادي الى
اليوم الشعار هو فتح طهران كيف يمكن يعني
ان يعطي الزخم للتظاهرات اكثر باختصار لو
سمحت
في عام 2019 كان العام الاردني همم
اقتصادي ولكن اليوم وما نشهده اليوم هو
ايضا تمت اضافه عليه العامل الاجتماعي ان
هناك فئه او شريحه من المجتمع اي هم
الشباب والمراهقين والنساء يريدون حقوقهم
الاجتماعيه والخاصه بالاضافه الى الضغوط
الاقتصاديه الموجوده هي اصلا اعتقد هي هذه
سوف تؤجل الوضع اكثر
والذكرى الثوره 2019 سوف تشهد احياء كبيره
يعني حشود كثيره احتقد حسب ما كان لانه
حتى في تلك الثوره كانت الجماهير غاضبه
واليوم هي اكثر غضب من تلك ارسنال شكرا
الاحوازيه حدثنا من اصله
يلا
[موسيقى]
ليس ببعيد عن ايران
واخر من الجنسيه المزدوجه الجورجيه
والايرانيه
الجريمه الذين يعيشون في الخارج ومن بينهم
الشخص الذي امر بالقتل واثبت التحقيق وان
مواطنا باكستانيه في هذه المجموعه
الاسرائيلي في جورجيا
نتيجه نتيجه
وكذلك الهواتف المستخدمه في الجريمه كما
خلصت المعلومات الى التجهيزات المسبقه
لمحاوله الاغتيال وموقع الاختباء بالاضافه
الى ادله اخرى وفي اطار التحقيقات كذلك تم
الكشف عن اشخاص اخرين شاركوا في محاوله
الاغتيال وقدموا تسهيلات
سكان العالم يتخطى 8 مليارات فرصه
للاحتفال امن الفزع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في الولايات المتحده
المشهد السياسي يزداد تعقيدا لدى
الجمهوريين بعد نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه
التي كانت مخيبه للامال مع اقتراب اعلان
ترامب ترشحه رسميا للانتخابات الرئاسيه
القادمه والتي فتحت طبعا باب التساؤل حول
مستقبل الرئيس السابق ترامب ومواقف اعضاء
حزبه المتضاربه من تواجدها على الساحه
السياسيه ومدى قدرتها على لاعب ادوار
مستقبليه مهمه فتراب الذي لا يزال يحتفظ
بشعبيه لا يمكن انكارها يستعد للاعلان عن
ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
للعام
2024 رافضا دعوات من بعض الجمهوريين
بالتراجع وهنا تتزايد المخاوف من دخول
الحزب الجمهوري في دوامه الفوضى الداخليه
خصوصا وان ترامب يسع هذه المره لتحطيم فرص
منافسيها المحتملين بمن فيهم ديسانتوس
ونائبه السابق فمع اقتراب موعد الترويش
حوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه يبدو ان قبضه
ترامب الحديديه على الحزب الجمهوري تتصدع
فبعض الجمهوريين بعض منهم لم يعودوا
متاكدين حتى مع ان مع ترامب انه قادر على
القياده وفقه ما كشفه متابعون لصحيفه
بوليتيكو
[موسيقى]
ساقوم باعلان كبير يوم الثلاثاء الخامس
عشر من شهر نوفمبر
وساقول باقوى طريقه ان الانتخابات المقبله
ستنقذ البلاد
العديد من الجمهوريين يرون ان ترامب تسبب
بتشكيل عواق عوائق سياسيه وتصدعات داخل
الحزب بدعمه لبعض المرشحين دون البعض
الاخر في انتخابات التجديد النصفي الاخيره
ووفقه صحيفه بوليتيكو ايضا فكيف بار
الجمهوريين دعوا اترام لتاجيل اعلانه
للترشح الى ما بعد جوله الاعاده في مجلس
الشيوخ في جورجيا الشهر المقبل وافقه
مراقبين لتطورات الحاصله فان اشد حلفاء
ترامب المخلصين رفضوا تقديم الدعم له ففي
مجلس النواب حيث يحذر ترامب بتاييد اكبر
كما قال البعض انهم سيراقبون عن كثب اطلاق
حمله ترامب المحتمله لكن القليل منهم
كانوا على استعداد للالتزام بتايده وقالوا
بان الاولويه حاليا هي لاعاده العمل من
اجل السعاده بس تراب الذي اختار البقاء في
الساحه السياسيه
ومواصله تجهيش مناصريه انتخابيه في
انحاء البلاد يمكن ان يعيق طموحه للعوده
الى البيت الابيض عدد من التحقيقات في
سلوكه قبل ولايته الاولى كرئيس وخلالها
وبعدها وممه قد يؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى
استبعاده ايضا وفق بعض الصحف الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من واشنط مراسل العربيه حسين
الطوب حسين سنبدا مع الاعلان الذي اعلن
عنه ترامب ما المتوقع منهما متوقع المضمون
في وكيف هي يعني اصداء هذا الاعلان قبله
وسط الجمهوريه
تحيه لك ليال من المتوقع معروفا ومعلوما
ان يعلن ترامب عن ترشحه لانتخابات
الرئاسيه عام 2014
داخل الجمهوريين هناك انقسام على ما يبدو
من خلال المواقف التي نسمعها هنا الكثير
من الجمهوريين الان يطالبون ترامب الترجيس
همم بان لا يعلن عن ترشحه خاصه
معركه معركه مجلس الشيوخ لم تنتهي بعد
صحيح ان اا ال- ال- حسمت من حيث السيطره
عليه همم ديمقراطيون الان لهم الاغلبيه
ولكن معركه جورجيا بالنسبه لهم مهمه
ويريدون من ترامب ان يتريث بالاعلان عن
ترشحه وان يدعم جزء كبير منهم يطالبون
يدعم هرش الواقر خاصه في المناطق النائيه
في جورجيا حيث الاغلبيه الحمراء الجمهوريه
ويقولون
لن يستطيع الفوز بمقعد جورجيا من دون دعم
ترامب همم خاصه
براين كام الحاكم الذي حصل على اصوات
كثيره لن يكون على ورقه الاقتراع وهو قد
ساعده اصلا
بالحصول على همم الاصوات التي حصل عليها
همم نعلم ايضا ان نورناك همم كان متقدما
على هاشم الواقع الان ب 35 35,000 وقد
يتقدم اكثر خلال جوله الاعاده بسبب عدم
وجود ابراهيم كامل ولكن في المقابل
ترامب قد يكون اي على هرش الوكر بما حدث
عام 2021 عندما همم جاء بجوله الاعاده
وساند المرشحين الجمهوريين ان ذلك
والمرشحات الجمهوريان فالشلاه في انتخابات
الاعاده لصالح همم ورناق ولصالح اوصاف
السيناتور الديمقراطيه الاخر الذي فاز عام
2021 اذا هناك انقسام داخل الجمهوريين
يتخوفون جزء منهم يتخوف من ان يكون ترامب
اثر سيء ويطالب كل شيء حتى تنتهي معركه
جورجيا وهنا كمان يقول بان لا على ترامب
ان يتدخل ويدفع من الاموال من اجل دعم
الكره خاصه في المناطق همم النائيه في
جورجيا وان يسانده بالحملات الاعلانيه
بجماعه التبرعات
ااا حسين يعني من يحمل ترامب اليوم
مسؤوليه خساره المعركه الانتخابيه ويلقب
اللوم عليه وهناك العديد من التقارير التي
تتحدث عن توجهات عند البعض الى وجوب يعني
ايجاد قياده جديده للحزب الجمهوري كم يشكل
هؤلاء هل ممكن ان يشكلوا انقسام حقيقي على
ابواب الانتخابات الرئاسيه
بالفعل ليال هذا ما بدنا نرصده الان ولا
سيما في ظل صعود نجم حاكم فلوريداس سانتوس
الذي بدا البعض من الجمهوريين يقول انه
همم القائد الفعلي للحزب الجمهوري ايضا لن
ننسى موضوع اخر لا يقل اهميه هو موضوع
مقالل همم
البارحه من خلال الاسبوع الماضي كان هناك
دعوات الى تاجيل انتخاب او الانتخابات
داخل مجلس الشيوخ بنسبه ليه زعامه الحسبه
الجمهوري العديد من الجمهوريين الان
يصطفون خلف وهو معروف عنه ان لديه مشكله
مع ترامب همم هناك عداء تقريبا بينهما
الان يصطفون خلف
خاصه بعد بعد النتائج التي وصفت بالسلبيه
بالنسبه لحزب الجمهوريه لم يستطيع ان يربح
مجلس الشيوخ همم بالنسبه لمجلس النواب
هناك الان توجهه اتجاه بان يفوز به بالفعل
لكن باغلبيه بسيطه ولكن كل ذلك
على ان شعبيه ترامب داخل الحزب همم او
بالرحله تاييد ترامب من قاده الحزب تزعزعت
كثيرا الان سنتحدثنا على المستوى الشعبي
همم تحليلات تقول بان من يؤيد ترامب من
الجمهوريين سيؤيده هو مع ترامب هو هو مؤمن
بان ترامب يمثل قائد له ولكن حينما تحدث
الان عن القيادات بالحزب الجمهوري خاصه
مجلس الشيوخ ومستوى مجلس النواب لا ومن
الواضح جدا لانه هناك انقسام حاد الان
وهذا ما
نستشعره من خلال ردود الفعل التي نقراها
شكرا لك حسين الطوب مراسل العربيه حدثنا
من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
اظهر فيديو جديد نشر على مواقع التواصل
احلام البشير السوريه والتي زرعت العبوه
في احد المقااعد في شارع الاستقلال بمنطقه
تقسيم بتركيا وهي ترقد مسرعه قبل انفجار
العبوه لتنفجر بعد دقائق قليله
[موسيقى]
افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان بان
جماعه مسلحه مواليه لايران تجهز مقرات
جديده لها في منطقه الحسكه شمال شرقي
البلاد وكشف المرصد بان الجماعات المسلحه
تنويه فتح باب التطوع لجذب المئات من شباب
المنطقه وضمهم في صفوفهم مقابل الاموال
واشار المرصد الى ان نشاط الجماعه يقتصر
حاليا على استقطاب مسلحين دون التطرق لحمل
السلاح خشيه ان تصبح هذه المقرات هدفا
لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والقوات
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
اسره يمنيه الى اتخاذ احد المنازل المدمره
غربي تعز مسكن لها بعد ما نجحت من جحيم
الميليشيات الحوثيه ويبيد افراد هذه
الاسره يوميا داخل بقايا بنايه دمرتها
الميليشيات الحوثيه بقذائفها في حي المطار
القديم ما يجعل حياته هؤلاء معرضه للخطر
وتفتقر تلك الاسره مع عشرات الاسره
النازحه في تعز الى ابسط مقومات العيش
كالمياه والغذاء والدواء والملابس الشتويه
في المنزل هذا الذي بدا غالبيه جدرانه
مدمره اضطرت اسره الى اتخذه مسكن ومؤول
لها بعد انفرت من جحيم الميليشيات الحوثيه
فالسكن فيه مؤقت رغم انه اكثر خطرا على
حياتهم من ذاك الخطر الذي تهددهم لاعوام
في المنازل قبل النزول
الى هنا للمطار القديم
مدمر انا واسرتي وعائلتي
وانو اعاني من السؤال ما يشاء ومن القصف
ومن الحرب هذه
كل يوم قذائف مع الحرب هذا وضرب هون الا
الحاره والمواطنين وترحيب الاطفال
والمواطنين
غربيه
تشكو اليوم الوحده وقسوه المعيشه في ظل
الحرب
ظروفنا الخاصه
من هنا
والمستقبلين ما هو من الله بس الان يعني
اناشيد المنظمات واصحاب الخير بالايتام
الان ما فيش حد مني الفتهم ولا احد ولا هم
ولا من يجيب لهم ولا اي حاجه
اكثر من 3000
يعيشون الوضع نفسه مع التردد الوضع
المعيشي خاصه اولئك الذين يعيشون في
المخيمات فالغالبيه منهم لا يحصلون على
احتياجاتهم الاساسيه من الغذاء والملابس
الشتويه التي تقيهم اقل ما يمكن من البرد
سعيد العربي العربيه تعز
[موسيقى]
حاجه مع عدد من نشطاء المناخ لوحه شهيره
للفنان جستاف كلينت وذلك في متحف يقع في
العاصمه النمساويه فيينا وقالت مجموعات
انها استهدفت العمل الفني الذي يعود الى
العام 1915 بعدما قامت الحكومه في البلاد
باستخدام الطاقات الاحفوريه من جهاتها ذكر
او من جهته ذكر فريق المتحف ان الاضرار
التي لحقت بالزجاج والاطار الامني
بالاضافه الى الجدار والارضيه مؤكدا ان
الاضرار كبيره
كشف تقرير الامميه عن ازدياد اعداد سكان
الارض والذي بلغ 8 ملايين نسمه كما كشف عن
توقعات بان يصل التزايد في السكان او وصل
الى ثمانيه مليارات نسمه كما توقعت بان
يصل التزايد في السكان الى 9.7 مليار نسمه
بحلول العام 2050
[موسيقى]
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
باكثر من 100 صاروخ روسيا تقصف بعنف كياف
وخر كاف والفيف وتتسبب بانقاعات واسعه
للكهرباء والانترنت
وفي مجموعه العشرين اجتماعا على تفادي
المواجهه بين القوى الكبرى وتحريم استخدام
السلاح النووي
[موسيقى]
الارتباطه بايران دعوات لاغلاق مركز
هامبرك الديني والاستخبارات الالمانيه
تعتبره اداه رباندا لطهران باوروبا
اندرويد
عام 2014
يتسبب بالقسمه داخل الحزب الجمهوري